-Now, I thought I'd share some
of my favorite
"College In Six Words"
responses from you guys.
This first one is from
@Abbylampe.
She says, "If it's due tomorrow,
do tomorrow."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This next one's
from @ryanbartholomee.
He says, "$150 textbook sell
back for 5 bucks."
And that's
[ Laughter and applause ]
That is so true.
-One beer.
-Yeah, that is barely one beer
Yeah.
This one's from @itskatelambert.
I wonder if that's her,
or if she says that
as she was signing up
for twitter, like,
"It's Kate Lambert."
Oh, no.
-Oh, shoot.
She was doing it in her phone.
-@itskatelambert.
She says, "Febreze counts as
actually doing laundry."
-Yeah, come on!
-That's true.
-It does.
-All great advice.
This is from @alexsch99.
-Sch99?
-Sch99.
-Alexsch99.
She says, "One white claw won'
kill me."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-One's too many
and a million's not enough
-Yeah.
[ Light laughter ]
Then an hour later, "Six white
claws won't kill me."
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @joshuagrotheer.
He says, "Just know that C
get degrees."
-Yeah!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-This is one from @taughnee.
She says, "Food or beer,
food or beer?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's college in six words.
-That's it, yeah.
-Ugghh --
-Beer.
-This one's from
@jenlinnriddell.
She says, "Way before social
media. Thank God."
[ Light laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Come on.
-Our crowd is very young.
-Very young.
-Yeah, but if you were in
college before social media...
-Ask your parents.
-Yeah.
This one is from
@ariannanicolexP.
She says, "Failing 17 classes,
only in 6."
[ Laughter and applause ]
College in six words.
This is from @krissyyelyse
She says, "When in doubt,
nap it out."
[ Laughter and applause ]
This one's from @jackyboy223
-Yeah.
-He says,
"I'm never drinking again,
until tomorrow."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's a good one.
-They're all winners.
-That's a winner.
They're all winners.
-Yeah.
This last one here is from
@TOP5LIST5.
-Wait a second.
-TOP5LIST5?
-TOP5LIST5 is the name
of this person.
@TOP5LIST5.
-What is it?
-[ Light laughter ]
-College in six words.
-Six words.
-He says, "Best eight year
of my life."
There you go, everybody.
Those are the "Tonight Show"
hashtags.
Check out more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags